The sheer scale of the refugee crisis in Bangladesh.
Hundreds of thousands of Rohinga Muslims are
living in squalid camps - just like this.
They've fled Myanmar because of army-led violence
following a military crackdown.
But with agreement from Myanmar, today Bangladesh
begins the enormous task of trying to repatriate
them.
It's a move that is proving deeply unpopular.
"The Rohingya community leader told me that
my number has been listed and I have to return
to Myanmar.
But my son and daughter were killed there.
I cannot pray there.
No one talks about our rights there.
We were sent away after being labelled as
'Bengali.'
We will not go back there."
This family have fled the Bangladeshi camp
they called their home and are in hiding - so
fearful are they of returning to Myanmar.
They have tortured us so much, there are no
words to explain it.
We went through so much pain and if we go
back again to face the same, then why should
we go?
It is better to die here by taking poison.
There, we will have to stay in camps.
We are already in camps here, so it is better
to die here.
I feel that I will die here, so don't try
to send us there."
Aid organisations and the UN refugee agency
admit there are still concerns for the safety
of those who do return.
But nervertheless the work to repatriate 150
Rohinga a day is underway.
Bangladesh`s Refugees, Repatriation and Rehabilitation
Commissioner
"We are still talking to the Rohingya refugees.
Our people are working on the ground to encourage
them to go back.
Our associated organisations are also working."
Life in camps like this is far from easy.
But for many Rohinga staying here is far better
than being forced to return back home.